etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video der leute ich hoffe
natürlich sehr dass google heute datet
der zweite part von ich versuche bares
geld mit alten defekten zerstörten
beschädigten iphones zu machen hat beim
friseur der hat meine haare auf jeden
fall komplett in die falsche richtung
das teil sieht bisschen komisch aus ich
würde sagen wir den ersten part noch
nicht gesehen habe wo ich die alle aus
gefragt habt schickt es auf jeden fall
erstmal ab jetzt ist der plan ich habe
nämlich einen guten kontakt jemand der
das hauptberuflich macht diese dinge zu
reparieren wir haben nämlich einfach
einige iphones die kann ich nicht
reparieren ich weiß das würde ich
niemals hinbekommen weil der staat
einfach viel zu groß ist die iphones bei
denen ich nur den bildschirm austauschen
muss das werde ich selber machen das
werde ich auch filmt und wir bringen
jetzt erstmal die ganzen anderen zweck
und sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich erst
morgen wieder ich muss nämlich auch noch
die ganzen ersatzteile bestellen dann
wird sich daran befriedet wird auf jeden
fall super gespannt und ich hoffe das
experiment endet gut und ich werde auch
nicht was verdient wir werden sehen
deswegen bleibt auf jeden fall dran und
ein handy ihr kennt mich wird am ende
doch wieder an irgend jemand von euch
verlost spaß mit dem video leute was
geht ab es sind jetzt ungefähr etwas
mehr als sieben tage vergangen ich sitze
hier wieder in meinem büro und habe eine
gute und schlechte nachricht fangen wir
erstmal mit der schlechten nachricht an
ich habe aktuell erst zwei geräte die
wieder komplett funktionieren aber
vielleicht schon fast zu sagen die sehen
aus wie neu was ja schon mal was ist was
noch besser ist das ein iphone ickx und
einfach sag' ich euch mal kurz wir haben
hier einmal das iphone ickx und hier das
iphone 8 dieses jahr hat er laut des
verkäufers so ein paar schäden und ja
ich irgendwie manchmal abgestürzt das
wird alles behoben ich persönlich habe
das nicht gemacht aber ich habe jetzt
hier noch ein iphone 6 plus was wir
jetzt zusammen beim reparieren werden da
muss noch eine neue akku rhein und der
display muss getauscht werden mal
schauen ob wir das ohne probleme bekomme
ich habe das auf jeden fall schon mal
gemacht ich habe noch das iphone etwas
ich nicht selber gekauft habe sondern
von meinem kumpel was auch noch
repariert wird das problem ist da war
auch der akku kaputt und das hat eine
sperre also muss erstmal gesperrt wäre
sonst kannst damit sowieso nichts
anfangen ich habe das in meiner wohnung
zeige ich euch mal eben das problem ist
mein letztes handy das ist nämlich schon
auch noch ein kleiner hoffnungsträger
von mir das ist ja nicht eins weiß ich
selber gekauft habe sondern vom kumpel
von mir immer hier das problem bei
diesem ist auch das hat noch eine
rot-sperre das heißt er muss dort sein
passwort einmal eingeben es fährt
allerdings nicht hoch der akku ist
defekt und deswegen bestelle ich jetzt
einfach noch schnell neuen akku bau den
da ein und hoffe dass es dann
funktioniert das er das dann entsperren
kann dir sehen hinten sieht so aus aber
ich kann trotzdem verkaufen oder ich
kaufe auch noch neues case das werden
mal sehen weil sonst habe ich ein
bisschen angst dass wir hier einem
minusgeschäft obwohl ja seid gespannt
ich muss ganz offen zugeben und zwar in
youtuber celtics hat auch mal so ein
ähnliches spiel gemacht werde ich euch
hier ein paar legt ihr euch in der
viehbestand schickte grüße an dieser
stelle und jetzt haben wir weiter und
hier in der kiste haben wir auch die
ganzen anderen iphones viele
686 plus auf 7 mit wasserschaden ich
habe natürlich gehofft dass wir noch ein
paar mehr handys reparieren können und
an sich hier zum beispiel das siebener
mit wasserschaden da kann man einfach
nichts mehr machen wir werden mal kurz
telefonieren mit dem experten weil er
mir echt auch sehr geholfen hat und ich
glaube da kann das am besten erklären
und mir war es auch super wichtig dass
dies professionell gemacht wird einfach
weil ich keinen stress haben will welche
verkauf und ich bin nun mal kein
technikexperte der einfach mal so zu
100% einfach wieder fit macht hatten wir
bei dem iphone iks das hat ja ein paar
fehler gehabt dass der lautsprecher und
das gerät war schon mal in die maschen
da habe ich eben die lautsprecher presst
nicht mehr soldaten sich über schrauben
gelöst hatte kontakt quasi zum doc und
nicht mehr bestand dunkeln da ist jetzt
quasi auch wieder eine echte schule
zwischen display und rahmen damit als
als eine gewisse wasserdichtigkeit
spieler da ist nur einmal deutlich
garantieren und dann hast du glaub ich
aus zwei iphone 81 gemacht ja genau
richtig bei der einheit von acht
unendlichen sind drin
nachvollziehen konnte vor irgendwelchen
hersteller der rest folge meiner weise
kann man beim bitte anrufen lästige
aufnehmen nur ich hab getestet ob die
gegner da sind gerade dieses war nicht
gekommen es war nicht vodafone das war
nicht allzu weit da kannst du nichts
machen ja deshalb haben wir das aus beim
1 1 gemacht haben wir uns messen
reparatur geworden das backcover kaputt
das hat das hat sich gelohnt dann haben
wir noch das eine einfach nix vor den
akku mrt gemessen und dann hoffen wir
dass das auch wieder gegner richtig und
es scheint doch austauschen dhl handys
waren zur verfügung und vier
funktionieren jetzt korrekt gut kann man
ja mit arbeiten ich danke dir auf jeden
fall dank für die infos an diesem iphone
6 plus versuchen wir jetzt selber hier
muss der bildschirm gewechselt werden
und der akku dass auf jeden fall schon
mal gemacht mir auch ganz interessant
set besorgt
[Musik]
ja wo ist denn gegen kleinere dann
machen wir uns jetzt mal hier an den
home button ich bin aber auch nie ein
tier am main und auch jetzt hier am 17
becker gibt auch mal zählen verbringen
also ich glaube das ist falsch ich habe
mich komplett
jetzt ist wirklich es ist so eine firma
arbeit aber ich werde zu schaffen wir
haben aber glaube ich gerade leichte
technische schwierigkeiten leute das ist
manchmal echt richtige fummelarbeit
diese schrauben sind so klein ich hab
das jetzt zum zweiten mal gemacht haben
oder das display getauscht und es
funktioniert ist alles wieder sieht
super aus das display zumindest ja die
rückseite hat ein paar schrammen aber
wir haben jetzt hier ein voll
funktionsfähiges iphone 6 + ich sage das
jetzt 50 minuten ran ich bin echt
gespannt ob sich das am ende lohnen wird
nächster tag leute und ich melde mich
direkt mit einer guten nachricht das
iphone ist funktioniert wieder das heißt
wir haben jetzt vier handys die
funktionieren ich hatte ein bisschen
angst dass ein paar fehler hat hat
anscheinend nicht also kann ich es auch
so verkaufen und das machen wir jetzt
denkmal ich stelle die dinger rein und
dann schauen wir mal ob die sich gut
verkaufen aber ich gehe eigentlich davon
aus ich werde nicht bei ebay verkaufen
sondern auch vom eigenen shop lucky
bonn.de warum soll ich dir irgendwann
das verkaufen wenn ich einen eigenen
online shop ab und da sind auch täglich
immer genug leute drauf let's talk
iphone iks mit 64 gb mir völlig
natürlich muss man dahinter schreiben
bin ich mal gespannt ich denke so 300
euro kann ich dafür schon verlangen also
hier 315 euro alles über 300 euro ich
würde sagen ich verkaufs für 295 oder so
dann ist das doch an sich auf jeden fall
ein top preis dafür wäre es rein stellen
haben wir noch eins mit 128 arbeit was
allerdings ja nicht so gut aussieht wie
das andere iphone ex muss ich sagen weil
es wirklich nicht mehr in diesem top
zustand ist würde ich denke ich so ich
bessere 270 oder so verkauft da kann man
glaube ich nicht meckern das ist ein
fairer preis hinzu kommt dann noch ein
iphone 8 mit 64 gb ebenfalls ja das kann
man eigentlich nur als gebraucht
verkaufen weil das hat leichte schreiben
am displays ich würde aber sagen sonst
ist es auch in einem guten zustand das
ist dann jetzt schwierig kann eigentlich
nicht sagen es ist in einem sehr guten
zustand weil das hat leichte kratzer am
display aber einem nur guten zustand
vielleicht auch nicht vielleicht hier so
ein mittelding also ich denke 180 190
euro für das ding ist ein fairer preis
da kann man nicht meckern und dann haben
wir noch das iphone 6 plus mit 16 gb
soweit ich weiß ok 115 euro
20 euro ist aber auch in einem
vernünftigen zustand deswegen gehe ich
hier auch einfach mal so mit 125 euro
rein muss sich aber auch weil sonst
werde ich kein plus machen am ende ich
habe ja auch materialkosten gehabt 30
euro hat das gekostet das display zum
beispiel von dem 6h das kann man schon
mal wieder abziehen und so weiter und so
fort ja ich stelle die sachen jetzt rein
für die dies interessant finden so sieht
das ungefähr aus wenn ich in meinem
online shop halt ein neues produkt
hinzufügen ich mache das ganze sie mit
jockey feier das ist so ein programm
dafür also ich habe alles eingetragen
ein phönix 64 gigabyte hier ist ein foto
290 euro heruntergesetzt von 320 oder
ich hab mal so gesagt hier mal daumen
verkauft man die sonst für 320 euro 1
habe ich auf lager gewicht zack zack
zack zack jetzt habe ich das noch eine
kategorie gepackt aktiv speichern und
schon ist es online das mach ich mit der
abend für uns auch an schauen wir mal
ich denke morgen sind die weg ok ich
hoffe ich lehne mich nicht zu weit aus
dem fenster ach so und was ich noch gar
nicht gesagt habe ich habe ja auch noch
sieben iphones die natürlich alle nicht
mehr funktionieren aber ich kann sie
trotzdem alles perfekt weiterverkaufen
das werde ich auch machen alle auf
einmal 420 euro oder so einfach weg bin
mir aber sicher dass die sich auf
verkaufen leute was geht wir
mittlerweile schon samstag ich war jetzt
drei tage noch in köln ich habe aber
gute nachrichten und zwar habe ich
einmal das iphone ist schon verkauft sie
können wir sind
hier stets ausverkauft wurde verkauft
und auch das iphone 6 ist einfach macht
leider noch nicht und das andere habe
ich noch nicht eingestellt aber das gar
kein problem wir gehen es erst mal hoch
in meinem büro und dann werden wir noch
mal alles durch recht dann schauen wie
viel am ende über bleibt weil das ist
auch für mich überspannt ich muss auch
sagen wie viel das ganze gekostet hat
ich bin auf jeden fall mehr gehabt und
ich hoffe dass am ende über 350 warum
kommt wir werden sehen okay leute was
gehabt ich habe jetzt zwei tabellen
einmal aufgelistet wie teuer was war was
defekt war das zeigt euch mal eben und
in der zweiten tabelle habe ich genau
aufgelistet wie viel geld ich für
welches iphone bekommen hat
beziehungsweise safe halt bekommen werde
auch wenn ich jetzt zwei noch nicht
verkauft habe wir starten hier oben aus
den beiden iphone 8 wurde einst gemacht
das ist jetzt voll funktionsfähig da
musste man auch nichts neues für
bestellen also deshalb praktisch erst
mal gar nichts gekostet dann hatten wir
einmal iphone 7 was leider defekt ist
dann hatten wir das iphone ex und silber
was für ein paar macken hatte der
lautsprecher funktioniert wenn ich das
hat er so einen software-fehler manchmal
wurde alles behoben das habe ich ja
nicht selber repariert aber hat auch
anscheinend nichts gekostet muss ich um
ehrlich zu sein man nachfragen ob der
lautsprecher nichts gekostet hat
wahrscheinlich halt nur 23 euro deswegen
hat das hier nicht mit aufgelistet dann
haben wir das zweite iphone ist was ja
noch nicht funktioniert hatte es
funktioniert aber jetzt ich bin euch
hier das foto ein das ist an das nur
noch einmal das case getauscht werden
das kommt allerdings als nächste woche
dienstag an und ich würde das video
gerne morgen joggen dann kann ich es
aber auch verkaufen also das wurde auch
repariert da war das backcover und der
mittel rahmen defekt beides zusammen 80
euro plus dann nochmal neuer akku 35
euro also 115 euro reparaturkosten dafür
das ding ist nur ich weiß halt auch für
219 euro weiterverkaufen hier die
restlichen handys sind leider alle
defekt bzw
da lohnt sich nicht die zu reparieren
und die hat mir aber noch ein iphone 6
plus base grau 16 gb dort wird einmal
das display getauscht 40 euro das habe
ich ja selber gemacht großen neuen akku
rund 20 euro also die kosten für akku
und dispens klemm 60 euro verkauft habe
ich das schon an bekannten von mir für
120 euro also ich denke dass das auf
jeden fall in ordnung also muss man
leider festhalten dass wurden nur vier
von den elf handys repariert was
natürlich echt schade dass ich habe
gehofft dass wir sieben oder acht
schaffen nur ist es ja auch gut zu
wissen dass es sich halt meistens sich
lohnen und einfach extrem schwer es ist
eine iphone iks habe ich schon für 289
99 verkauft hab ich mich schon gezeigt
dass andere noch nicht das kommt halt
erst nächste woche in shop würde ich
einfach für das gleiche geld verkaufen
dann haben wir noch ein iphone 8 weiß
ich auch nicht verkauft habe aber ich
denke das geht safe in der nächsten
woche auch weg also da auch noch mal 180
euro für das iphone 6 plus habe ich
verkauft 120 und dann nochmal alle die
defekten iphones zusammen für 129 euro
99 insgesamt landen wir dann bei 1009
eur 690 für alle iphones zusammen ist in
ordnung da muss ich jetzt allerdings
schon mal 500 euro abziehen weil ich hab
die ganzen einfaches jahr für 500 euro
gekauft dann noch 60 euro fürs iphone 6
plus 115 euro fürs iphone iks landen wir
bei 334 euro 96 bloß unser experte der
ja drei dieser iphones repariert hat
bekommt natürlich auch ein stundenlohn
er meint er hat ungefähr fünf stunden
für alles gebraucht hätte ich das
natürlich alles selber gemacht könnte
ich mir das sparen ich konnte es nicht
beziehungsweise wollte es auch nicht
weil ich wirklich wollte dass alle
iphones wieder reibungsfrei
funktionieren und ich auch keinen
schritt weiter verkaufen will 15 euro
stunden und würde ich mal sagen klar
wenn man es wirklich professionell
machen lässt bringen solche leute viel
mehr geld landen wir bei
[Musik]
259 euro 96 ich muss sagen ich habe mir
eigentlich deutlich mehr erhofft aber
ich bin zufrieden damit sollte und bevor
wir zum fazit kam habe ich am anfang
gesagt ich verloren auch ein iphone
dieses iphone 8 habe ich ihn noch nicht
verkauft deswegen schreibt einfach einen
coolen kommentar und seite cooler
zuschauer und dann wird das demnächst
aufgelöst jetzt kommt zum fazit ja gut
und das habe ich vergessen zu erwähnen
eigentlich hatte ich auch noch viel neue
lightning kabel kaufen müssen ich hatte
allerdings vor welche die absicht
zugelegt aber werde ich dazu lägen also
fällt dafür jetzt kein geld an aber ich
weiß wenn man bei mir ein iphone kaufen
oder nicht mein körper es auf jeden fall
kommen jetzt das fazit dieser ganzen
iphones defekt kaufen reparieren
weiterverkaufen geschichte wenn ihr euch
mit diesen reparaturen selber gut
auskennt und alles halt selber machen
können so wie ich es jetzt nicht gemacht
habt kann man sich vielleicht als
schüler oder student damit schon ein
bisschen geld verdienen es wird
allerdings nicht viel sein also man kann
davon eigentlich denke ich mal nicht
leben der experte so wie ich ihnen immer
in meinem video nenne hat mir auch
gesagt dass er es lange zeit selber
gemacht hat das lohnt sich nur einfach
nicht weil es ist so oft so dass iphones
einfach kaputt sind da kann man dann
wirklich einfach nichts mehr machen ob
das dann auch diese icloud sperren dann
sind die sowieso unbrauchbar so weit ich
weiß ist es jetzt ab dem iphone 11
sowieso extrem schwer das zu reparieren
weil man das halt gar nicht mehr auf
schrauben kann und somit wird dieses
geschäft dann halt auch immer um
lukrative trotzdem finde ich meinen
gewinnen über 259 euro 96 absolut in
ordnung und kann damit leben ich bin ein
halbwegs zufrieden ich hoffe ihr könnt
ein bisschen was lernen mit diesem video
auch wenn ich halt nicht alles selber
reparieren habe das ging einfach leider
nicht ich hoffe ihr nicht übel danke
fürs zuschauen lassen nach oben da
abonniert super g den kanal für weitere
experimente und videos würde ich mich
darüber freuen und wir sehen uns die
woche haut rein